the Joe Rogan experience now is this
because you guys don't have I mean how
much of influence do record companies
have on new bands like when new bands
are coming up and they're trying to put
together their music how much influence
the record companies have on the
creative process it just depends that
they discover them or they already are
the are they jumping on board with
something that's already working well I
mean someone like as an artist like
someone looking at you as an artist to
go yeah you'd let him do whatever the
[ __ ] he wants you know like let him know
that's a very rare thing it's rare well
you're exactly with record companies
right yeah yeah I had I got it
contractually written into my contract
that nobody could tell me what to do so
it's common that you get [ __ ] with
well everybody's gonna have their two
cents and footers are gonna here's what
we really want you to want to do right
because like this broad probably I would
think there would be executives to go
stop stop [ __ ] with it right there
just leave it right there trust me put
it out like that those would be like
actual record men the guys that used to
run the record business like they knew
what the real [ __ ] was and you don't
[ __ ] with the real [ __ ] but there's very
few of those people actually working in
the record business anymore it's all
like 25 30 year-old bottom line
quarterly report [ __ ] it's all
about the money yeah but wouldn't you
think that excellence would bring money
I just special II today in this Dainius
with the internet say we sell excellence
yeah then they have to work and find it
has athos is like formulating this
tried-and-true
Mrs Butterworth recipe proven yeah you
know just give me 17 of those I get it I
would just what suck to be in a business
with art you know or like you're
thinking about it like a business yeah
but it's art mmm it's product but your
muse enough people involved anything
turns into a product right yeah but it's
just the the business aspect of it like
someone trying to think about what's the
best way to sell it what's the best way
to what's the best way to push it what
if we changed this and added that a
little put some gospel singers in the
background what if we did this what if
we you know mm-hmm
yeah but you've avoided it what if we
get this person to like crap reverse on
it how'd you avoid it
what did you what did you do to avoid
most of that [ __ ] still figured it
out I don't know man just didn't do it
I say no a lot I think that's the thing
to say yeah yeah I'm lazy as [ __ ] I got
to really want to do something yeah
especially when you don't have to right
right
man what were you doing at 35 when you
quit mmm we're gonna railroad where I
was the operations manager a really
order a intermodal yard out in Utah why
we running a rail yard uh just
overseeing the switching crews that when
the trains would pull in from the east
and west side of the yard we would break
those trains apart and like look at
other manifests and drag cars off of the
rails and build them into those trains
and then crew him again and get him on
Milan I was working like 90-hour weeks
mostly cleaning up train wrecks and
derailments or like they blew a switch
and put three cars on the ground we we
we were the central artery in the
Midwest or really that that corridor is
kind of the cross section of the entire
country's shipping commerce so if we
[ __ ] up
and tied up the main lines then we kind
of shut down the railroad do you know
what's [ __ ] up you could never tell a
kid hey you want it you want to make
meaningful music this is what you got to
do you got a struggle and like difficult
jobs till you're about 35 and but you
know barely get to where you want to be
where you're really kind of freaking out
about your future and then pour yourself
your heart and soul and then find
success after that that's a good move if
you want to have impactful music but if
you if you get into music like early on
in your life and make it career early on
in your life you miss everything that
you did by being an older like you're
you know a 35 year old man that makes it
jump yeah that's I mean an old move that
makes sense but there's been a lot of
incredible artists that made some truly
visionary [ __ ] at 20 you know for sure
but there's a life experience aspect to
your music we I mean I wouldn't know
what the
when everything [ __ ] the right about if
I'd done in 220 yeah I'll be right with
God knows what I'd be right about
probably [ __ ] yeah for sure for sure
yeah and you're young well what are you
thinking about you know if you're
talking about stars and horoscopes and
[ __ ] you're probably bullshitting people
[Applause]